Hey YouTubers it's Charlie. This is my episode
seven video the gift just like all the other
episodes this season that title is a metaphor
for several different things on the show as
well as a literal thing once of giving and
receiving a very unexpected amazing gifts
so people for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet and new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do enter is be
Subscriber and leave a comment on this video
just starting with top seven WTF moments number
seven Maester Aemon Dunk and Egg shout out
Maester Aemon in his fever dream as he lay
there dying starts calling out to his brother
Aegon Targaryen the fifth that's Egg from
the Dunk and Egg series just one of the many
spinoff series that they could make I totally
feel like a Dunk and Egg spinoff series would
be really awesome they can even reuse that
map that they use of the opening title sequences
because all the places are still the same
Duncan egg as a series mostly covers the time
when egg is growing up I did a video for Aemon
targaryen mostly deals with Aegon as an adult
after he ascended the throne two very different
points in time a grew up in the time after
the first Blackfyre rebellion the other really
cool thing about egg is that he is Daenerys's
great-grandfather his son was Jahaerys his
son was Aerys the second and then obviously
he had Daenerys on December 6 Sansa asked
Theon for help I feel like anybody hoping
things the got better for sense of this episode
were sorely disappointed she has bruises all
over her clearly like what happened with her
last week is been happening with her every
single night since then I can hear the outrage
pouring from the Internet she is basically
getting the fake Arya storyline from the public
the gene pool storyline Sansa is expecting
it to play out like that dozen the books one
of the problems with Kim throws the show is
that they do everything so far in advance
so if there's something that just you everyone
absolutely hates if they're going to address
it they have to wait till the next season
to do that so I give everyone really hates
what they've done with Sansa's character and
how did they kind of put her down so they
can put this Ramsey storyline to the forefront.
Like it's more of a Ramsey storyline and the
Sansa storyline they can't address that till
season six so whatever ends up happening dissents
of the season it is set in stone given that
week the tracer for Ramsey I think the hope
now is is vigil take her feet into her own
hands like Scholz will do something crazy
to try and get rid of Ramsey just a moment
when Ramsey casually showed her her servant
woman who had been flayed and hung up is just
so horrifying is so casual to like it's no
big deal I think he did that a little bit
because Sansa epistemology with all the pastor
talk I've been naturalized by royal decree
well yeah you got naturalized by another Bastard
Sansa is it wrong and I think that Ramsey
now is probably gonna try do something about
that baby inside Southwall the does a lot
of people that feel like Ramsey might be like
the new Joffrey the series will see if it
doesn't end up playing out the exact same
way I mean I hope not to become a predictable
the only real bright shining moment in all
this is that Sansa now knows that John snows
doing just fine he is Lord commander she seemed
really surprised when Ramsey mentioned them
I don't think she's forgotten about them I
think just so much crap has happened to her
that she hasn't had time to think about them
she's mostly spending her time trying to not
get murdered on to number five Stannis's army
is starting to fall apart I like the shot
after the storm crows in winters coming is
just not a star saying it is literally coming
seriously like look how hard the snow is blowing
up at Winterfell just in those normal scenes
during the middle of the day in the context
of the series it kind of already is early
winter but when they say you know winter is
coming like it in the role final sense that
means it's snowing in Kings Landing so we
were still ways away from that the real WTF
here though is that Melisandre suggests that
they sacrificed Shireen and nice dad that
he is Stennis is in hearing any of it they
really didn't positioning him is like the
nice guy this season he hugs his daughters
he complements people like Samwell is doing
all kinds of stuff that you never thought
when you first saw him season two was aerobic
Stannis arc and he kinda seems like an acyl
during that season Ramsey isn't wrong though
Stannis just is not used to fighting in heavy
snow and Ramsey's family the Boltons there
totally used to it so they have the advantage
even though Stannis has way more men I know
you said that they lost 500 they lost the
storm crows but they still have a huge army
on summer for the continuing saga of Samwell
and Gilly Samwell is that the Milhouse of
the series so whenever he stood up to those
other brothers were trying to rape Gilly I
just thought everything is coming up Milhouse
and goes talk a little bit yeah AME pry Woodinville
to do that without ghosts but still this is
like a bad ass Samwell moment or the closest
you get to it like the moment when he killed
the white walker Gilly tells Sam to always
take care of little Samwell no matter what
that that's her baby you can make as many
taking care of little Sam jokes as you want
you know that with the sex scene that they
had but isn't it funny how they reverse the
roles in this unit typically you know that
the things that Gilly did would be something
done by a male on-screen but Samwell in this
scene was kind of like the really soft female
character I just like the way game of thrones
plays with gender roles like say you know
Brienne and Jamie had a scene like that she
would probably be the man and he would probably
be the woman ligula Tumblr pick that up and
run with it but I think Sam and Gilly's relationship
is the one of the most genuine ones initial
one of the most believable ones I usually
don't get really excited about stuff like
that your but like Jamie and Brienne that
you know they have one of the most compelling
relationships to but you get the sense that
they're never going to end up together it's
can be really tragic relationship Samwell
Gilly on the other hand feels like something
that might end up sticking but onto number
three the Queen of thorns and Littlefinger
conspired to get rid of Cersei every seen
on the show is made better by the presence
of the Queen of thorns she is like the MVP
of this episode she just like isn't having
any bow shipped from anyone this week how
surprised are you that she admitted that they
killed Joffrey together we all knew it but
it still surprised to hear her say it out
loud just because there's so many years listening
in Kings Landing because there aren't a lot
of people floating around Littlefinger's flesh
market nowadays since it's been trashed but
still she's taking a big risk being so open
I just love how honest they are with each
other you even though Littlefinger speaks
in riddles I have a gift for you the same
gift I gave to Cersei a beautiful young man
obviously he was talking about Lancel but
just just the way that they're so open with
each other we both have very incriminating
evidence on each other and we have a common
enemy so while we work together really the
most dangerous threat that she has is to just
cut the grain off from Kings Landing and try
and starve them out but the High Sparrow answered
that dudes by saying we are the many will
do whatever it takes to get rid of the few
meaning that all he would need to do would
just march all the peasants on Highgarden
and take the grain is a lot of big threats
flying around and most of them end up being
empty really it seems like the High Sparrow
is now the most powerful person in Kings Landing
on summer two Daenerys and Tyrion meet for
the first time this is so much fun even watching
tearing in the slave market sell himself becoming
a like the reverse Joffrey's lap when he suggested
that they pay them away just the freedmen
my have the tables are turned the look of
hope though I doors face the minute he heard
the word Queen it is so fun to see them just
kick everyone's ass in the stadium the sequence
of events was a little predictable but I really
did love like that big jailer helping Tyrion
now but he is like okay fine here we go buddy
manometry some mercy is crazy as it is in
Slavors Bay right now I know I think they
still want you to think of Daenerys is a good
character the one associate that storyline
with the idea of mercy so I think will continue
to see people being charitable to one another
with with a few exceptions like the people
that they actually want you to think of his
films the same things happening with Stannis
right now you know he'd never hear you sacrificing
his daughter that WTF looked on Daenerys's
face was so much fun but she's a deer caught
in the headlights is like I don't know what
to do with this information now Tyrion Lannister
what's this all about the ideas that Tyrion
is going to help her with her people problem
in Meereen you he is a great source of wisdom
bears isn't there but you hopefully he'll
show up eventually and I'll have like a real
small counsel for Daenerys a group of people
they can give her the advice she needs Daario
is someone who's really honest with her but
he isn't necessarily the smartest person for
managing a city Daenerys isn't just in the
middle of a war right now you he is great
at making war grade infiltration small special
ops but he's no ruler so you're taking his
advice your his first red wedding idea could
lead to some really bad repercussions was
felt like they heard the rain the cast near
playing softly in the background when he suggested
that she she Roundup all the heads of the
houses in Meereen and kill them Daario might
still be something you know little bit crazy
he sounds a little bit jealous of the thought
of her marrying Hizdhar he's jealous in the
books but you know I think this shows Jason's
just a little bit different with this character
we finally have Tyrion with Daenerys is a
huge freaking deal I feel like it'll play
out pretty good like it is not to take some
dramatic left turn but finally my number one
WTF moment so I cannot exploit this between
the sand snakes and Bronn with Cersei versus
the High Sparrow so much out of us and thinks
first never before has everyone held their
breath so much as when Bronn was sitting in
Maxell singing loudly in tiny fan asked him
how he was feeling she had the same knowledge
of poisons is her father over Martelle I so
you know he coded the ship out of his blade
whenever he was fighting the mountain he got
those with way more poison but were you not
remember he is like three times the size of
Bronn so even just like a little bit would've
killed him almost instantly an account is
what happens to me they weren't really clear
on the timeline like how long this moment
happens after he got Nick put the blade but
it seems like it's relatively quickly I thought
they should put that song on the soundtrack
though I've tasted the Duwamish men's wife
I will say that the mechanism by which he
got the antidote was a little contrived I'm
not really sure whether taking the stance
fixes season you but tidying you just like
taking all her clothes off to tease Bronn
there might be something going on there later
this season he takes the antidote so he enemies
totally sticking around the wall that was
happening my eyes you know floated to the
background and you can see old Barro and Nymeria
just rolling their eyes in the back of their
heads given where there are kids right now
I don't see a whole lot more fighting going
on inside Dorn the real question is is what
is Prince Durango going to do with Jamie because
Jamie doesn't want Myrcella to stay in print
strand doesn't sound like he's too hot on
the idea of Tristan marrying Myrcella really
want to see how this is affected by what's
going on with Cersei in Kings Landing because
that'll probably influence what print strand
decides to do and finally Cersei versus High
Sparrow so this is you know one of the big
moments as a book reader I was waiting for
I was so happy when it finally went down Cersei
is one of the most smug characters in the
books and she's been in asshole all season
long so watching the High Sparrow just choke
the hope out of her was so much fun she was
defiant to the last but the moment her eyes
started darting across the room looking for
you know whatever he was talking about till
Lancel walked out that with that was so great
sometimes some of the best performances on
the show are ones that don't involve words
you know just people using facial expressions
to convey really strong emotions so much is
going on on Cersei's face right now so many
things going through her head on the to go
out on a limb and say she's prior not to find
the same mercy from the mother Loras and Margaery
might find it's going to be such a fun twist
on the trial that tearing out last season
will see the plays of the same white there's
so much going on right now they so much stuff
this teeing up the last couple of episodes
here's is my big question what do you think
is going to happen when Cersei goes on trial
and do you think that John is going to end
up using that Dragonglass dagger that Samwell
gave them it's been all season we haven't
seen a single white walker I feel like if
we are going to it's going to happen up there
Hardholme I thought feel like that Dragonglass
dagger's going to be used so suggest in general
like the weakest storyline this week was stances
just because it did nothing to address what's
going on with their like it seems like a dead
end at this point unless she does something
to save herself she's going to be like the
damsel in distress again for another season
the hope was that this year she would take
a darker turn it would start taking care of
herself with the love three episodes for her
to do that so that there is a chance that
she could turn around strongest storyline
this week obviously High Sparrow he is on
a roll in Kings Landing but the MVP of the
episode was the queen of thorns she is not
nearly as big a presence in the books but
Diane Rigg is just so amazing with all his
of the characters like her scenes with the
High Sparrow that was so much fun I I just
hope that they get a couple more this season
so just a quick reminder on the do Q&A tomorrow
so ask all your questions is there so much
that we have to talk about this week I will
announce the winner of the giveaway in that
video it if you have any requests for next
week's bonus video just let me know in the
comments so while you guys wait for the Q&A you can click
here for Maester Aemon's history
and you can click here for last week's episode
thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's High five and i'll see you tomorrow!